David furnishes half of one of the
world's most famous couples a prominent
campaigner in the fight against AIDS the
rolling back of gay rights and in
lockstep with his husband Sir Elton John
over what he describes as the homophobic
treatment of Phillip Schofield without
question
Phillip Schofield and Elton agrees
behaved inappropriately
and it could be perceived as an abuse of
power I think the media's response and
only certain parts of the media were so
disproportionately large and cruel and
personal that to me it felt like
homophobia because I don't think we
would have had the same response if it
had been between a man and a woman at
his home in Windsor David furnished also
spoke out about what he sees as a tax on
trans rights and explained why he
disagrees with JK Rowling I have
tremendous admiration for what JK has
done with Harry Potter I don't like to
see any Community singled out or
stigmatized and I think when you have a
platform like she has
um
if I was in her shoes I would direct it
towards doing what I do best which is
bringing people together through my
through my work and through my art and
my culture protective two over the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex he received a lot
of flack for taking the stand he's had a
difficult few years how's he doing now
he's taken a lot of flack in the media
and you have to remember he's taking on
the media so what actually happens in
the courtroom and what you read about in
the newspaper are often two very very
different things he was very pleased the
way things went in court and he's doing
really well good next for David furnish
and Sir Elton a new 100 million pound
initiative to try to end the AIDS
epidemic by 2030 but before that this
weekend sees Sir Elton swan song the 76
year old Superstar performing his final
UK concert at Glastonbury he's got four
different collaborators joining him at
stage at different times I think he's
he's anxious yeah but I think good
anxious healthy anxious he just thought
I'd really like to do something with
these artists at Glastonbury a big
weekend for a mega star couple still
with so much to do when it comes to
battling AIDS Beth Rigby Sky News